hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
for my bonus video I'm going to be
talking about the Mad King some someone
who has been mentioned a lot but mostly
been used as a punchline on the show in
the context of the books his story is a
little bit more tragic he started out as
a really promising King but through a
series of unfortunate events across his
lifetime and as a result of the
hereditary problems of all the Targaryen
inbreeding he descended into madness
and became the person that Jaime talked
about during Robert's rebellion but in
real life he's actually much closer to
Caligula one of the famously insane
Roman emperors Caligula is just one of
the most extreme examples of the mad
Roman emperors there were many of them
but look at it this way Caligula was
also killed by one of his Praetorian
guards just like Jaime a Kingsguard
killed King Aerys Caligula also invited
the head of mauritania to Rome then had
him executed which is a little bit like
what happened to Rickard stark it's a
really loose connection but I noticed
everyone likes to find real-world
examples of characters in Game of
Thrones because George R Martin is such
a real-world history buff
so rewind to his father King Joe Harris
the second Joe Harry's interestingly
enough is the son of Aegon v if you
haven't read the duck and egg series
it's currently the leading candidate for
the Game of Thrones spin-off series that
will probably end up being developed in
a couple years but Aegon v has G Harry's
the second in a couple of the children
Joe Harris is the one that ends up
ascending to the throne breaking from
Targaryen tradition Joe Harris marries
for love and has two children
Aries the second who went on to become
the Mad King and raela Targaryen but
generally as a child Aerys was described
as being generous but quick to anchor
not the brightest but generally a good
person he exhibited some of the traits
that we saw in Viserys to lesser degrees
he was a little bit vain intended to
collect a lot of sycophants around him
as a child but he was a prince so
naturally a lot of people are going to
be sucking up to princes but he and his
sister were forced to marry when they
were teenagers I would put them about
the same age as viserys and danerys were
in season 1 so when you see this image
here just imagine their parents getting
married like right after this moment
just as Daenerys is getting ready to get
married off to Khal Drogo
here's where things get really
interesting though the reason that Joe
Harris you know even though he had
married for love push so hard for Aires
to marry his sister was because of a
prophecy made by a woods which about a
prince who was promised now this is the
prophecy that Rhaegar Targaryen would
become obsessed with much much later a
very young Barristan Selmy was there to
witness the wedding and he just he says
that they really didn't care for each
other
Ares and his sister so definitely not a
happy marriage now like I said in my
Jaime Lannister video King Aerys was
afraid of Tywin Lannister just because
Tywin was probably the most powerful
person in the kingdom next to the actual
king but as children they were really
close friends Tywin Lannister was
actually King Aerys page as a child and
he was also really good friends with
Steffon Baratheon
now that's Robert Renly and Stannis his
father so just putting him in this
context Aerys goes from being this
punchline during Robert's rebellion to
being this really tragic figure because
house Baratheon House Targaryen in House
Lannister all used to be really close
friends so what happened to change that
well right around the time Aerys first
son was born Prince Rhaegar the tragedy
it's summerhall happened that's a really
infamous fire at the Targaryen summer
house in a place called summer Hall
that's in the Dornish marches right here
the fire killed Aegon v who was still
king at the time I mean he was a really
old person but remember this is egg from
Dunkin egg it killed him a bunch of
other Targaryen in the family so Jo
Harris the second ascended the throne so
Aerys isn't King yet he's still a prince
in half of the Targaryen family just
died in a mysterious fire in Dorne if
you haven't read role device and fire
there's actually a rumor that the night
that Aerys father Jo Harris the second
took the throne Aerys took Joanna
Lannister's Maidenhead that just means
that he took her virginity a lot of
people have heard the theory that Tyrion
might secretly be a Targaryen
personally I don't believe that but that
does throw a little bit of gasoline on
the flames grand maester pycelle in in
the context the narrative says that
these rumors aren't true as Tywin
Lannister would have never married
another man
leavings that is his way of saying that
Tywin Lannister does not go down for
sloppy seconds but then we move on to
the war of the ninepenny kings
now King Aerys was still a squire
whenever the war started but during the
war he was raised to knighthood and
chose Tywin Lannister to dub him with
the honors so at this point they're
still really good friends House
Lannister House Targaryen haven't had
their big falling-out if you've never
heard of the war of the ninepenny kings
it was just a group of people in the
Free Cities that took over and then set
their sights on Westeros then within a
really short amount of time like just
within a couple years of being crowned
king J Harris the second heirs his
father died so Aerys ascended to the
throne so we have his father ascending
the throne the War of the ninepenny
kings being knighted and then being
crowned king all within like this really
short amount of time just add a little
perspective aires ii was around jon
snow's age when he ascended the throne
in the books it's just that you know
like when when the narrative picks up
John snows around 16 years old in Aries
ii was around 16 whenever he went into
the war of the ninepenny kings so cut to
book five you know john snow went say
like season 5 episode 10 is going on
that's about the age aries ii is being
crowned king of the Seven Kingdoms I'm
not trying to fan any rumor flames or
anything like that but I think that's a
really interesting connection so really
young King Aerys implements some
sweeping changes in King's Landing
there's there's a bunch of old people
sitting on the small council he gets rid
of all them in names Tywin hand of the
king
he's like okay I'm young I'm gonna
change everything make everything fresh
and new so for the first dozen years or
so of arias reign everything is great
like he he holds court on a regular
basis there's lots of balls lots of
merriment he has lots of mistresses he
has lots of very short-lived love
affairs so he's of it you know he's very
passionate man he had all kinds of crazy
plans that he never followed through on
like he talked about building a second
wall like a crazy 700 foot second wall a
lot of people attribute the prosperity
of Aerys early reign though to Tywin
Lannister's shrewdness he's the one that
actually kept the machinery of the
kingdom working he even used his own
Lannister gold to pay back loans that
the Iron Throne owed to the iron bank at
the time think about that in present day
now the throne is
seriously in debt to the iron bank now
you understand why Tywin was so
reluctant to pay for everything himself
whenever Joffrey was crowned like the
purple wedding and then Tommen's wedding
after that like he tried to bargain with
the Queen of thorns about who would
share the cost for Margaery and Tommen
wedding
the real bitterness between areas and
Tywin started when Tywin got married to
Joanna Lannister got married to his
cousin Joanna and on the wedding night
King Aerys got really drunk and boasted
that he took Joanna Lannister's
Maidenhead so Tywin is sitting there and
you can just imagine him making this
face as King Aerys is telling like the
entire banquet hall that he had sex with
Tywin's new wife then over the next
several years Eris started to go a
little bit crazier and a little bit
crazier his wife raela lost a series of
children to stillbirths and it slowly
drove him crazy he became convinced that
she was unfaithful and then had her
confined to makers holdfast then finally
Viserys was born Aerys was so paranoid
that he had Kingsguard stand watch over
the baby day and night he was so afraid
that it would die the year after that he
actually held a special tournament in
honor of his son at Lannisport
now that event actually was going on
when Cersei was visiting Maggy the Frog
so when we see young Cersei here in
Episode one that's during the tournament
at Lannisport
in honor of Viserys birth then if things
hadn't already been bad they really went
to [ __ ] during the defiance at dusk and
Dale this was an event where Aerys was
held captive for over half a year now he
wasn't super tortured like Ramsay
tortured Theon Greyjoy but imagine
psychologically that the same kind of
thing is going on so now you see how
Aerys goes from being like a really
crazy person to being a mad person
in fact after he was rescued the reason
he started to look like Howard Hughes
like you know get really long hair
really long fingernails is because he
was so afraid of blades he wouldn't
allow any near him so no one could trim
his fingernails or cut his hair that
that's why he got so gross then we get
to the tournament at Harrenhal that this
is like Rhaegar Targaryen supposedly
setting the stage for calling a Great
Council to depose his father who is
clearly nuts like everyone recognizes
that the king has gone completely mad I
talked a lot about that during my Lyanna
Stark video so I'll add a link to that
in the description but
then we get to Robert's rebellion which
I talked about during my Jaime Lannister
video so I won't duplicate those too
much but essentially the King just
slowly goes mad makes some really bad
judgment calls ends up having Rickard
stark in Brandon his oldest son burned
by wildfire cue the music BAM Jaime runs
him through so really like the point of
this is just to point out some of like
the really unfortunate things that
happen in King Aerys life that slowly
drove him crazy er and crazier until he
went from being nuts to being full-blown
mad a lot of people draw comparisons
between Joffrey in the Mad King just
because Joffrey was so crazy but the Mad
King was never as bad as Joffrey when he
was Joffrey's age and you could argue
about this but I would say neither of
them is quite as crazy as Ramsay Bolton
is being portrayed on the show right now
they've kind of turned him into like the
real evil of the show like there are a
lot of bad people in the Song of Ice and
Fire
but right now on the show the biggest
villain is Ramsay Bolton that's a good
question you guys can let me know who do
you think is crazier the Mad King
Joffrey or Ramsay Bolton I know everyone
wants Ramsay to die in some spectacular
way but one of the problems with that is
that he is just like so interesting on
the show and I feel like the more
interesting you are the longer they'll
keep you on you could point to Oberyn
Martell like he was one of the most
interesting characters of season 4 and
he died within a single season of that
that was part of a book plot Ramsay
Bolton has gone way off book at this
point so just as a reminder I talked a
little bit about Aegon v egg from duncan
egg that book a night of the Seven
Kingdoms is going to be released in
October so I'll be giving away a couple
of copies of that and there's actually a
new round of the giveaway right now if I
forgot to mention it all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll be doing a
Q&A tomorrow so leave all your questions
all announced the giveaway whenever
whenever I post that always so much fun
talking about crazy people but in case
you haven't seen it I posted it a long
time ago but you can click here to watch
my Lyanna Stark video I talked a little
bit about the tourney at Harrenhal like
the knight of the Laughing tree in
Rhaegar Targaryen suppose it plans for
the Kingdom and you can click here to
learn all about the x-force movie that
Fox is developing which is just like the
crazy cranked up version of x-men thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
so get ready to blow out your collective
sphincters cuz my trailer is coming